ah vsauce kevin here
i've got 23 babies which means there's a
50 chance two of them have the same
birthday
huh let me explain each one of these
babies has a random birthday
meaning that they each have the same
chance of having been born on
any one of the 365 days
in a year so what are the odds that two
of them
share the same birthday we'll keep it
simple
no twins no leap years no
patterns that suggested parents made
their babies at
non-random specific times the odds
aren't 23 out of 365
which would be about six percent the
odds are actually
50 percent there's a 50 chance that out
of
23 random people two have the
same exact birthday
which seems impossible given that we've
got so
few babies and so many possible
birthdays and if we have 50 babies
the odds of a birthday match jump up to
97
at 75 it's 99.97 percent
making it a virtual certainty that when
you get 75
babies together or 75 things with
birthdays they don't have
to be babies two of them will share
a birthday the birthday paradox is a
veritable paradox it's surprising and
absurd sounding but we have the math
to prove it's true how is it possible
that so
few babies can have such a high chance
of
sharing a birthday and how is it that
despite
365 possibilities we only need
a sixth of that number to be pretty
sure there's a match the easiest way to
do this
isn't to excuse me babies
babies oh geez oh geez
babies erasing babies all right that's
not good the easiest way to do this
isn't to calculate the probability that
two
of any number of babies share the same
birthday
it's to calculate the probability that
they don't
to do that we assume that baby number
one
has been born so the probability of this
baby having a birthday
is 1 or 365 over 365.
then we multiply that by baby number
two's probability of
not sharing that birthday 364 over
365. we multiply that result by baby
number three's probability
of not sharing a birthday with either
baby number one or
baby number two which is 363 over 365
and we keep doing this for as many
babies as we want to calculate the odds
for
at baby 23 we're multiplying by 343 over
365.
to simplify this calculation we can
write it as
364 factorial we'll start with 364
because
365 over 365 is just one
over 342 factorial because 365
minus our 23 babies gives us 342
times 365 days out of the year
raised to the 22nd power which is our 23
babies
minus baby one again okay
and the result of the whole equation
gives us
0.492703 or about 49.3
again that's the probability we don't
have a birthday match with 23 babies
so we subtract this from one to find the
chance that we do
which is 0.507 0.507297
which is about 50.7
the trick here is that every baby is
being evaluated against each other
it actually broke my pen trying to make
all these evaluation
lines it's it's not whether babies two
through 23 share a birthday with just
baby one
to have a 50 chance of a match with a
single pre-defined birthday like
like a 50 chance of finding a match with
baby number five specific
birthday we need a pool of 253
babies which sounds about right and
isn't
particularly surprising this is whether
any two babies share any birthday with
one another the high probability 50
with a low baby count 23
is surprising but the math works and if
we keep
extending the series the results show
that with 100 babies
fewer than a third of the possible
birthdays in a given year
the chances of a match are 99.99997
percent
which means the chances of not having a
birthday overlap
would be just point zero zero zero zero
three percent or
three in 10 million if we replace our
birthday babies with online passwords
we've got the basis for a type of hack
known as the birthday attack
when you make a password for a website
that password is crunched into a fixed
length hash value
that stores and identifies the
combination of characters you input
so like 1 2 3 four five becomes
eight two seven c c b zero e e a
eight a seven zero six c four c three
four
a one six eight nine one f eight four e
seven b
simple when the md5 message
digest algorithm was a standard for
encryption its 128 bit
32 hexadecimal hashes were vulnerable to
a hack
based on my babies
the goal was to find and force a
collision when two hashes have the same
exact value regardless
of what that value is so like if
vsauce2.doc and
kevin.doc had the same hash value
i could change information in one and
affect
the other or i could eventually use
collisions like this to decode the
encryption algorithm
itself and learn how it works
and the best way to do this wasn't a
trial and error or
brute force attempt to guess a specific
match
in the 3.4 times 10 to the 38
possible outcomes it was putting the
birthday paradox
to use hackers developed an algorithm
based on the math of the
birthday paradox to more quickly cause
hash collisions
and ultimately crack one of the most
widely used cryptographic
algorithms of its time so
probability surrounding birthdays helped
lead to the improvement of internet
security
and right now online as long as
70 people are watching this video at the
same time
there's a 99.9 percent chance two of you
blow out your birthday candles on the
same day
of the year so
when were you born and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you